el síndrome del túnel carpiano ocurre
cuando un área estrecha que rodea la
muñeca conocida como túnel carpiano se
inflama y presiona el nervio mediano que
pasa a través de ésta con el tiempo esto
puede ocasionar adormecimiento
cosquilleo y debilidad progresivos en el
lugar donde el nervio mediano envía sus
ramificaciones a la palma y los dedos de
la mano afectada el síndrome del túnel
carpiano por lo general afecta a
aquellas personas que tienen trabajos
que requieren que se repitan exactamente
los mismos movimientos de fuerza con la
muñeca una y otra vez también puede
presentarse a raíz de lesiones en las
muñecas artritis reumatoidea o cambios
hormonales o metabólicos una banda
resistente de tejido denominada
ligamento carpiano transversal se
extiende a lo largo de la muñeca
formando el techo del túnel carpiano la
liberación del túnel carpiano es un
procedimiento quirúrgico mediante el
cual se corta esta banda y se libera la
presión del nervio aliviando de esta
forma los síntomas del síndrome del
túnel carpiano
al llegar al hospital para someterse a
la cirugía se le colocará una vía
endovenosa y es posible que se le
ofrezca algún medicamento para ayudarle
a relajarse la liberación del túnel
carpiano se puede realizar con anestesia
general que lo mantendrá dormido durante
todo el tiempo que dure la operación con
bloqueo nervioso regional que lo
mantendrá adormecido desde el hombro
hacia abajo o con anestesia local que
mantendrá el área de la muñeca
completamente adormecida una liberación
del túnel carpiano sin complicaciones
por lo general lleva entre 30 y 90
minutos
hay dos maneras de realizar la cirugía
en el procedimiento abierto tradicional
el cirujano realizará primero una única
incisión en la palma y la muñeca
el cirujano luego separará los tejidos
subyacentes hasta alcanzar el ligamento
carpiano transversal y cortarlo creando
de esta manera más espacio para el
nervio mediano
una técnica más nueva y mínimamente
invasiva requiere sólo dos pequeñas
incisiones en forma de ojo de cerradura
o punciones en lugar de una única
incisión relativamente grande el
propósito de esta técnica es que el
periodo de recuperación sea más corto y
menos doloroso el procedimiento comienza
cuando el cirujano utiliza instrumentos
cortantes denominados trócares para
realizar dos pequeños orificios o
puertos en la muñeca y en la palma de la
mano
el cirujano luego insertará un
dispositivo de fibra óptica a través del
puerto de la muñeca las imágenes de la
cámara se aumentan y se proyectan en un
monitor que se encuentra en el quirófano
utilizando instrumentos que se pasan a
través del otro puerto
el cirujano cortará el ligamento
carpiano transversal al finalizar
cualquiera de los dos procedimientos las
heridas se suturan
después de la cirugía se le colocará una
férula en la muñeca y el antebrazo y se
lo trasladará al área de recuperación
posquirúrgica para monitorearlo de ser
necesario se le administrarán calmantes
para el dolor dado que la liberación del
túnel carpiano es un procedimiento
ambulatorio la mayoría de los pacientes
son dados de alta a las pocas horas
deberá arreglar que un miembro de su
familia o un amigo lo lleve a su hogar